I just made a Hot Wire "Styro- Slicer" that traces out
styrofoam shapes with an impressive amount
of precision and control. It’ll create 3D
puzzles for entertainment and decoration,
or help you craft a custom styrofoam sword,
for cosplay or metal casting. The wire blade
can be set to any angle you need, and perhaps
the best part is, the whole thing compacts
together easily, for quick and clutter-free
storage.
Styrofoam usually isn’t the nicest stuff
to work with.
If you snap or break a piece in half, it’ll
spew a mess of tiny, styrofoam balls that
stick to just about everything. And even if
you try cutting it with scissors or a knife,
the pieces still come out jagged, and look
terrible.
But not with the “Styro-Slicer”.
There’s a much easier way to form your foam,
and all it takes is a simple hot wire foam
cutter, like this one I made out of low cost,
and easily accessible materials.
The heart of the “Styro-Slicer” is a thin,
stainless steel wire that uses electricity
to slice through any thickness of styrofoam
you want.
As the wire gets hot, it melts through the foam
pieces like a hot knife through butter, leaving
some of the cleanest and smoothest edges,
imaginable.
The little spring at the top is there to help
keep constant tension on the wire as it expands
and contracts with the heat, and looking at
the side of this improvised “foam factory”
you’ll see a red switch, and an adjustable
dial.
The dial is for fine-tuning the temperature
of the wire so it’ll slice faster, or slower,
depending on your skill level and the kind
of material you’re working with.
And the red switch boosts the system from
normal power, to "overdrive". I’ll show you
what that does in just a minute.
Now watch what happens if you try gluing something
like a custom paper template to the top of
the styrofoam, and setting it to about 30%
power.
You can see the foam cutter still glides easily
through the styrofoam, but notice how it doesn’t
actually go through the paper.
This means you now have the option, of using
your own custom paper shapes as cutting guides,
to produce really clean and professional looking
props.
I went ahead and made some custom 3D weapon
art, like a styrofoam handgun, as well as
an arsenal of “Mini Master Swords”, which
I’ll show you how to make yourself, in two other project videos.
The base of the Styro-Slicer is an 18” work
surface that gives plenty of room for most of your hobby projects.
And if you attach a straight-edge to one of
the sides you’ll be able to slice and dice
perfectly clean lines, like never before.
Now "normal" power is the mode you’ll typically
use for cutting foam and tracing templates,
but if you need a little extra boost, simply
flip the red switch to "overdrive".
This instantly gives you enough power to cut
through balsa wood, and burn through paint
sticks, like the kind you get from the hardware
store.
I’m not really sure why you’d need
that much power, but the option is there, just in case you do.
And check this out. If you have to quickly
step away from your project, just click the
button on the side to instantly kill the power
and stop the cutting.
Withn 3-5 seconds, the wire’ll be cool enough
that you can actually touch it by hand. And
when you’re ready to get going again, just
press the button, to pickup exactly where you left off.
But that’s not all.
The "Styro-Slicer" is designed to shape foam
blocks up to 8 inches tall, and the Slicer
arm can be adjusted to make beveled cuts as
well. Up to 45º on the work surface, and
over 180º when used by itself.
What’s really cool is if you position the
arms horizontally over the base, you can actually
cut styro-slices, as thin as you can imagine.
And if that’s not enough, simply unscrew
the wing-nut at the back of the support, and
you’ll see the entire wire saw comes right
off, giving you the option to cut larger styrofoam blocks free-handed.
But wait, there’s more.
If you ever lose power, or want to operate
off the grid, simply unclip the backup battery
cable, and hook the clips, to the terminals
of a 6v lantern battery, and you’re back in business.
These cheap and easy modifications make it
so you can take your “foam factory” just about anywhere.
And if your lantern battery dies on you, rather
than throwing it out, try hacking it open
so you can repurpose the carbon rods inside,
to build a “Mini Arc Furnace”, like the
one I showed you in a previous project.
The Styro-Slicer is made completely out of
low-cost and easily accessible materials,
and can take as little as 5 seconds to set
up and start working.
It’s also designed to snap back together
ergonomically, so it takes up as little space
as possible, when you’re finished, and ready
to put it away.
Well now you know how to glide through styrofoam
with ease, and create amazing styrofoam creations on a budget.
You’ll just need to build your own “Styro-Slicer”
first, but I’ll show you how to do that,
in another project video.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
project, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com